okay it's time for hatred mail hatred
mail of course the much loved and much
despised segment in which a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hatred mail that I get
this week's is a special one but first
just a reminder about what hatred mail
is because we cling to our guns and our
God but somehow totally cool with a
billionaire who wants to assault our
wife Patriot man written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay
so this week's hatred mail there's are
just a really great word in it I'm not
even going to say anything else but
let's take a listen let's take a look
David Pakman spends 50 minutes dancing
around semantics like every other NPC
David Pakman is the epitome of NPC
journalism why is Parkman audience
weaponized autistic you are Jewish and
this administration is anti-semitic
what's yet another rant from our
resident communist Pig mr. Patman yeah
epitome this is so funny epitome of
course is a mispronunciation of the word
epitome and if you don't know the word
and you see it spelled correctly you
might think it's pronounced epitome and
I remember every time I hear that word
pronounced epitome I think back to when
I was like I don't know how old I was
watching MSNBC and this reporter thomas
roberts who i'm sure is a great guy was
just reading off of his teleprompter and
he referred to something as the epitome
of something else and I immediately
realized I'm sure that it was spelled
correctly on his prompter but he clearly
doesn't know what that is
much like Bill O'Reilly not recognizing
what it means for sting to play us out
this evening in that infamous let's do
it live debacle Thomas Roberts not
recognizing the word epitome but I I
think that we don't really need to say
too much else other than NPC come on
that's so three months ago it's like the
cuck of six months ago no one's using
the term NPC anymore
was anyone even really using it
seriously to begin with let me remind
you the number one way to fight hate
reott ism in your own community is to
use the coupon code hey tree at forty
when you sign up for a membership on our
website now this is so funny
we started the coupon code hey tree at
forty years ago as sort of like a throw
away I said I'll just create a hatred
mail related coupon code for membership
I'll mention it only during hatred mail
segments and let's see if anybody uses
it to sign up probably very few people
will every week five to seven new
members sign up using the hey tree at
forty coupon code and it was something
that no one really thought would be that
successful so the way it works is the
membership of your choice at WWJ
pakman.com you apply the coupon code hey
tree at forty that's H 80 our IOT forty
and the price drops forty percent you
get 100% of the member benefits
including the bonus show and everything
else but you get a 40 percent discount
it's a beautiful thing and I look
forward to well welcoming new members
signing up with that code